même pas mal
[Musique]
étirements petit casse croûte et c'est
parti
sonic c'est bien de vouloir changer le
monde
et tu prend trop de risques
je prends trop pour batman lamblot
justin j'ai déposé la marque était
encore qu'un ado
trois mois il arrivera un moment où les
pouvoirs seront bien utiles
tu choisiras pas à ce moment c'est le
moment qu'il choisira ça me donne la
chair de poule didon entendu ça à la
télé chopra
[Musique]
papa s'est fait pousser la moustache
lors de mon voyage j'ai découvert la
source du pouvoir absolu
l'air puissant il ya un moment que
c'était sûrement to do list
concerne pas arriver trop tard mais t'es
qui toi même tu es ok alors voilà ce
qu'on va faire première phase on va
aller taquiner deuxième phase j'en ai
vraiment aucune idée
[Musique]
même pas mal
nos prévisions météo pour la journée une
avalanche davanture
[Musique]
on ne rêve pas tu leur as jamais mon
pouvoir
j'ai l'air d'avoir besoin de ton pouvoir
oh mince qu'elle malpolis sonic je te
présente note